klein out of the Sarlacc belly a boba
fett is going to join Mandalorian season
to a rescue of the son of Jabba the Hutt
and I also think Boba Fett and mando
will have a bit of a bond over the fact
that neither one of them were truly
Mandalorian blood
Bubba's started to regain consciousness
and with his last remaining slivers of
life grabbed a piece of his melting
armor and slashed his way out of the
Sarlacc belly this is rogue theory and
guys Mandalorian season 2 is like the
only Star Wars news we've got in a long
time but that's okay because Mandalore
is probably the thing we've been the
most excited about in the Star Wars
universe for a while now it's still
locked in for October so theoretically
we're gonna have something to look
forward to after all this and the big
news is that Boba Fett is going to be on
the show that's the thing that we all
thought the Mandalorian was initially
gonna be about was a return of Boba Fett
turns out season two is about that also
booked and joining in it's so good and
it's all kinds of stuff we're gonna get
really into it but I'm Phillip Melina I
don't even know my own name apparently
but who cares because Eric Foss is here
but also is because the real rejects are
here guys made into new rockstars notice
I'm so happy oh man these guys if you
don't know this is John Humphrey and
Greg Alba have you got some clarify for
the audience which of you is which John
Humphrey correctly we're all Eric Boston
Oh gross way so if you guys can real
quick just like shout out what you do on
your channel in case people don't know
what your deal is we do reactions but we
also like to provide as much commentary
as possible to the point where even if
the reaction wasn't there you'd still
get a full on video as well review
sketches once in a while too but yeah a
bit of big fan of new rock stars for a
very long time the second Eric came
on-screen while we were prepping for
this my heart sunk for a little bit and
I felt my personality shoot out the wind
I was like regain yourself
yeah that's a special power that he has
to steal your soul guys on this episode
we're also gonna be talking about this
su dark so gritty Batman movie that oh
it's never we've never had a gritty
Batman or wait wait we have there our
grip yeah I think murdered a baby or
something like lesson was so intense but
what I do like about is that there's an
Alfred angle to this whole Batman grit
that we're gonna get into but first Boba
Fett and Mandalorian season two there's
a lot to cover here I'm actually gonna
recap it for us normally we kind of jump
right into it but in case you've been
out of the loop on Star Wars news I'm
just gonna read off here what all the
new stuff we've learned recently so but
with that is gonna return played by
Tamora Morrison who played the father
Jango Fett I had voice boba fett and
other Star Wars things we got hints that
Boba Fett could have been the mystery
figure that was at the end of that
episode five moment in the first season
where you hear the Spurs and you know
people were like oh could that be bow
but maybe it actually was we also just
learned to época tan from the animated
series Clone Wars and rebels is also
gonna be joining him she's gonna be
played by Katee Sackhoff who I'm like
nuts about if you if you watch
Battlestar Galactica I've just been
sitting on my hands waiting for her to
get a role in something else I started
to think that she only existed in
Battlestar Galactica is such a badass
super excited for her she's the
Mandalorian that we saw wielding the
dark saber before moth Gideon showed up
in the season 1 finale and then just
reminder that frickin rosario dawson
cory booker's girlfriend is going to be
playing a live-action ahsoka tano the
central figure of Clone Wars and the
recent final season she's the ex Jedi
who helped pocket and liberate Mandalore
from Maul
okay we're all caught up everybody's in
the same page we know who cory booker's
dating for some reason now I want you
guys to pitch me here it comes
real rejects are you ready Eric Foss are
you ready how are these characters gonna
play into the Mandalorian season - how
did Boba Fett survive the Sarlacc how
will Bo Catan and ahsoka tie in I'll go
first if that's okay Greg John yes yes
please
all right Eric has never been happier by
the way he's like so tickled right no
it's just it's nice to have like
like-minded we always have like friends
and family I think but we have like
other guys that I see reflected in
Philip and me it's like some like-minded
super funny super smart nerds who do
just get it the way we get it so white
guy and oh boy okay so we would let the
privilege speak okay so we like saw Boba
Fett going into the belly of the Sarlacc
yeah so he's got to get out of that
thing
I think Kline out of the Sarlacc belly
Boba Fett is going to join Mandalorian
season two and he's gonna join forces
with ahsoka tano in a way that brings
her back to her first mission with
Anakin Skywalker a rescue of the son of
Jabba the Hutt okay so let's rewind a
little bit so baby Jabba little baby
chopped up little baby job I believe
that the way but that's gonna get out of
that Sarlacc is he's gonna use the tooth
of the rank or maybe they fed that rank
or monster to the star like to get his
digestive juices flowing he binds the
tooth in there and clogs out of the
stomach nice like so he's got a tooth
and he like rides it down the intestines
no no he finds the tooth in the
intestines we're gonna start the season
in the belly yes yeah he's gonna claw
his way out of it Mandalorian gauntlet
like Patton Oswalt said claws his way
out of the pit and that he finds his
himself in the wreckage of Jabba's
pleasure skiff everyone's dead but there
is one survivor
Jabba's teenage son rota the Hutt
aka stinky from the Clone Wars animated
film the first mission that ahsoka tano
and Anakin Skywalker went on together to
rescue this young Hutt so in order to
endear himself to the Hutt gang members
the the whole family of huts he takes on
this mentorship role to this Hut he
becomes a bodyguard to him
and then over the over the next couple
years he becomes a bodyguard meanwhile
we have the events of ahsoka tano and
boca tan from rebels who are now going
to be joining the Mandalorian and the
reason why it's mocha tan is looking for
the dark saber that it was stolen from
her by moth Gideon and now she wants it
back so they're joining the the
Mandalorian group with baby Yoda and
ahsoka tano tells Mandalorian all about
this is you know he's related to this
other famous Jedi he gives them the
whole backstory so what we find out is
that the reason finish and had a hit on
her in Episode five of the first season
is that Finnick Shan tried to kidnap and
was successful kidnapping this young
wrote to the Hutt stinky and only she
knew the location of where this Hutt was
that's why boba fett is going to tried
to find her body he's gonna try to snip
out some clues of where this young Hutt
is it he goes and he uh he hooks up with
ahsoka tano because she was a Jedi who
was able to find him before maybe she
can help find him again and she's able
to track down this road of the Hutt but
we find out that the hit was planned
because word of the Hutt's a little
stinker he was trying to like sell off
all the moisture farms to a third party
and he deserves to die and in the end
that's it now
AFET loves one in this young cut and
then mando feels like oh maybe this
young this young child who I'm training
will turn into a monster the way this
Mandalorian Dormer child turned into a
monster and he begins to doubt the the
intentions of young baby Yoda you you
vaguely just right at the end there
implied like it ends with mando having a
little gunned a little baby Yoda side
like I might have to do it yeah that's
that's what he's wondering at the end of
this arc is he's like what's gonna what
will become of this thing like what was
just because something's cute as an
infant doesn't mean it's gonna stay cute
its whole life especially if it has
powers this thing tried to choke Kara
doom that's gonna lead to some kind of
suspicion
yeah you heard it here first Eric Foss
wants baby you at a dead will pay any
cost any amount of credits yeah just to
be right that's the believe you Eric
I'm gonna give you right now you've
earned one row game okay so I'm gonna
hand that to you oh I'm gonna turn into
and it's gonna turn into a purple
Sparkle buck but I I you only have the
opportunity again anymore if you explain
like really what the hell is Amanda
doing the whole rest of the show
he just is like watching all this stuff
and then at the end he's like I might
need to kill the baby
no mando as I said once he meets ahsoka
tano he starts to learn the history his
whole journey is to try to get baby Oda
back to his home planet his home species
and ahsoka tano is the first one to
identify hey there was this other famous
Jedi guru who is the same race as this
thing we don't know too much about it
there was like an episode of rebels
where you could see like what looks like
a yoda species on a cave wall and maybe
bo Catan will be able to shed some light
on that but that's gonna be like the
mystery that they're following is
they're gonna try to find out maybe
Yoda's home species but this Boba Fett's
story will be like a side trip that that
teaches mando to be more suspicious of
this thing he's trying to protect I
needed each other it's just a tip for
the people who still have to go I I need
to see boba and I was gonna say buh-bye
Jon yeah Erik you get plenty of rookies
all the time you're very fine bear all
right who wants to go next Gregor Jon I
can go first alright samanda what he'll
do is he'll return to Tatooine where
he'll reunite with Pelley motto i think
that's how you say your name
pili mano played by what's your name Amy
Sedaris there you go Johnny help you're
getting from me and this is when we
first meet up this is what it's like off
camera all the time
this is when we first meet up with Boba
Fett and he'll be without his armor and
he'll have like this sense of shame kind
of think like a a little bit of like a
Logan esque kind of character and
because supposedly at the end of the
episode of gun slinger that we were
talking about earlier he approaches
fennec Shawn's unconscious body and
there'll be a tie-in to the famous Boba
Fett quote he's no good to me dead
revealing fennec Sean's character is
still alive and boba turned her in for a
reward however I think boba will have
gotten rid of his armor and live a life
of shame well I mean like why else would
this guy remain on Tatooine of all
places right so he's had a rough life
okay he's he saw his father beheaded he
failed to avenge him and he was taken
out by a blind Han Solo embarrassing not
into the Sarlacc pit now how he escaped
I think Dave Filoni will more than
likely like how he's done in the past
pull from the legend storyline grana no
that's not canon but i know it takes a
lot of inspiration from there but I
don't think he'll do like the whole
psychic connection thing I think it
would just be something simple like the
Sarlacc acid will come into play that
triggers his jet pack that burst him out
and he'll redo that scream that happened
in Return of the Jedi when he went in
bursting back and I think his encounter
with the Mandalorian will be twofold
essentially one will be a storyline that
ties into the possible history of baby
Yoda
there's been a lot of clues and brief
cloning discussion in the Mandalorian
series the scientists and Werner
Herzog's team as we know were the Kamino
patch from attack of the clones and so
this will take them back to the roots of
the initial science experiments on baby
Yoda the Navaro planet an and oh he'll
convince Boba Fett to come with him to
navarro in search of the answers that
boba might be able to help him out with
considering the Clone Army stems from
Boba's dad he's going himself and so
mando when he's back in Navarro
they'll come into contact with Paz villa
from the tribe who is already with Bo
Catan and ahsoka tano and Bo Catan came
here similar to Eric's upon hearing
about the conflict with Moff Gideon and
in my version she lost the battle The
Moth Gideon and that's
he got the dark saber and wanted her to
live with a sense of shame so but she
seeks to make things right because you
know he's knowing that he's causing all
this chaos and then we also learned that
ahsoka is personally helping because
when we last saw her she was setting out
on a new journey with Sabine Wren and
rebels and we'll learn here that Sabine
was actually killed by Moff Gideon but
maybe it's like a supposedly ambiguous
thing but I think this would be a good
driving force for ahsoka tano because
this can take a turn in the series where
if it sets up Mothe Gideon to be more of
like a centralized bad guy character for
the second season because he didn't come
in till like the last two episodes of
the first season so in this this one we
could have it be more of a focus of he's
you know whatever Darth Vader role
played in the original trilogy he's like
the central villain now because
everyone's after him and it could also
give a Sokka a turn where she's tempted
by the dark side because now she's on a
pure vengeance quest and Boba Fett
I think there'd be a cool part we'll
have like a moral conflict of turning
baby Yoda in for a reward but ultimately
he'll decide against it he'll choose to
do the right thing tying it back into
the themes of morals code and customs
and I also think Boba Fett and mando
will have a bit of a bond over the fact
that neither one of them were truly
Mandalorian blood yet their major
representations of them and in the end I
think mando will unite with the other
Mandalore's we saw in the series and
bring Boba Fett with him and in Episode
three of Mandalorian season one nando
was refusing a signet that was being
offered to him for killing the mud horn
and I think with Boba Fett's crazy story
of surviving and ultimately killing the
Sarlacc pit a punt escape he will be
given a signet and semi adopted in or
accepted into the Mandalore officially
and his armor will be restored as well
I love war although just go to the
cantina and they'll see him drinking
blue milk and it's just a quick cami
very logan esque or that just seems like
I'm just upset with you Greg I here's
why here's why I really like it what you
routed into Gideon being kind of like
the Vader where somebody was wrong with
him in the path wrong by him in the past
there's a vengeance tale there and that
suddenly took this character that was so
threatening and so fascinating right
away and gives him a at least personal
link to somebody who's gonna be
important on the show cuz right now
mando kind of has like a little bit like
yeah this guy I kind of now don't like
but it's it wasn't like my like my
life's goal to get back at this guy so
bringing in another character and that
really is like this is the one person
who I'm gonna go down fighting is is
probably a great way to really wreak as
much emotion and like tension out of him
continuing to be the villain so for that
oh my god I'm sorry here you say all
those nice things oh oh I will get this
contact fluid my eyes are always red and
looking like I smoked beforehand when
really that's just my contacts trying
out so this is really good no one buying
it no here's the second one I this pipe
that I need for my throat oh oh I'm
gonna take this multi-purpose dusters so
that way this new meeting can still
presume normally and get off the
computer
Office Depot just need supply all right
I love it I think that there's a little
strong motivation there exciting I still
would love to see a clash between mando
and boba but actually you have a solid
point of making them they're both
outsiders and finding a bond there John
give me the two guns to babyhood set and
make sure to include the thing yeah make
sure to include that if it doesn't work
just throw it in there so
Oh Brad I do it you mad on baby Yoda
guns also up there Eric's there yeah now
it's just a bunch of clones of Eric the
new clone army new works that was my
theory oh all right all right get ready
you guys because this episode of the
Mandalorians gonna knock your socks off
you're only gonna do one episode of the
minute this is shaping up to be a
two-parter okay okay but I I digress we
open on the desert pitch-black it's dead
of night except for the blue light that
the three moons shine on Tatooine and
you know we we panned down we see the
sand it's all tranquil and the little
space creature scurries by and the sand
starts to give way out suits a hand with
a decaying glove on it some cuts
someone's climbing out shedding sliver
after slitter of twisted metal finally
standing butt-naked under the moonlight
a figure he drops his helmet to the
ground and we see a familiar antenna
title card smash the Mandalorians season
2 all right so to be clear Sarlacc pit
life like so so mysterious like
silhouette appears by moonlight yeah
clear full frontal that's definitely
boba dick I appreciate your enthusiasm
already for my theme yeah like I'm TA
well that's that was part 1 of the
episode continues and we go back to the
present baby Yoda and mando they're in
their ship flying they going wrong there
but naked after shower and she stay
naked the whole time well I mean I don't
want to jump ahead of myself but this
take on Boba Fett does have a symbolic
nudity element because he is auto
wrapped in that cape that people say is
too long for him to be Boba Fett
well maybe Boba Fett living
out in the deserts of Tatooine has
adopted a robe to keep him from the
sandstorms and whatnot however anyway
president ain't interested Jim Zirin and
baby Yoda are evading they're caught in
some kind of dogfight someone's pursuing
them so they have no choice but to take
a little bit of refuge back on Tatooine
one of the last places they want to get
to meanwhile we cut back to shinnok fans
to fennec unconscious body coming to as
the figure now wearing that cloak picks
her up then she comes to in his little
desert hovel and this is where we first
mean we don't know who this guy is yet
but you know we're fans were getting a
sense so we establish here that fennec
and him they have a little bit of you
know connective tissue in their past
fennec is a little dazed and this guy
whoever he is is batshit crazy all right
he's not all there because and we will
learn this later but I'm gonna get to it
now cuz it's a part of the question how
did he escape in the Sarlacc pit well
I'll tell ya he was in there unconscious
for a long time acid burning through his
armor and finally coming to because of
the telepathy inside of the Sarlacc
Boba's started to regain consciousness
and with his last remaining slivers of
life grabbed a piece of his melting
armor and slashed his way out of the
Sarlacc s' belly no special you know
sacrificial teeth or anything like that
just a piece of his own armor yeah Eric
yeah there's a real competition wait but
hold on couldn't the acid touch the jet
pack and make it shoot off too that gets
him part of the way but that's not gonna
do it lacks heart which he then you know
has to Gore his way out of a climbing
rope to get out really quiet out of its
mouth yeah and then you know it falls
back into the sand because you know but
anyway so that's part of how this all
happened was you know the telepathic
link brought him back to consciousness
and then he gored his way out and was
left reeling from the experience both
physically traumatized mentally
traumatized images from his past life
from the future from all sorts of things
of the other Mandalorians perhaps we
don't know yet cut back John Havel yes
I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give you a
challenge you are killing it I am I I
would pay money for this I think it's
like so epic already but also I think
we're about as far into your theories
everybody else's and I know there's a
homeless man in a tent so I'm just
curious okay so as Ben akin boba unknown
boba are getting situated there is a
knock on their little hovel door
somebody shows up because this is the
hateful eight episode of the season this
kinda model we're gonna get a few people
here and so we have this traveler
character who doesn't really have any
business with fennec but she is on
pursuit of a rogue Mandalorian who
obviously worked for the dead speak word
travels through the galaxy she's on the
hunt for a rogue Mandalorian and the
dark saber that's how Bo katana gets
involved with this and then mando and
baby Yoda out in the deserts they're
wandering around finally they come
across the hovel and they're let in and
so it's just the five of them right now
unknown boba fennek mando and baby Yoda
and Bogut on and they're all in there
perfect hopefully yes and because this
is gonna be the episode where we dive
into the Mandalorian culture even
further because we have three steps we
have an authentic Mandalorian a raised
Mandalorian and by all accounts a
Mandalorian who is only really a
Mandalorian in image Dave Filoni has
talked about George Lucas being like
nope he's not an actual Mandalorian and
so that's going to play into the
belonging the culture the aspects of
their religion and whatnot because again
you have three levels of authenticity to
deal with putting them all at odds with
each other however they've all been
crossed by the empire and we're able to
through this establish that mando is not
the one who took the lightsaber even
though those stories meshed closely
together and so in this little bottle
episode
we have everybody at first year maybe
there's some fighting some scuffling
with the Mandalorians figure out their
junk but then to cap off the episode one
more figure shows up out of the
sandstorm
who is it it's ahsoka tano who's been
tracking mando and baby Yoda because she
senses that a very powerful very special
force user is somewhere out there in
need of training and she is here to do
that and it's at this point I mean we're
gonna cap the episode off with that
she's gonna get there and was gonna be
like whoa yeah the next episode we're
gonna learn about her and Bogut on them
you know in this joint venture together
and how that figures in and that's gonna
go down a whole other row that's gonna
lead us to mouth Gideon yeah and Boba
Fett was able to redeem himself and
they're both able to become full
Mandalorians it's great he gets some
clothes
he gets some clothes on eventually not
important not important you can put a
jet pack on a bare naked ass burn you
but okay so and to be clear at no point
is baby Oda between two pistols he's
between to make absolutely clad men so
yes between because man who takes off
everything except his helmet and then
Bobo's naked 10 Rogen one - oh really
oh characters wow you did wow you did a
lot of the things that I love for people
to do you made us feel like we were
watching it you went rogue
you didn't skimp on the x-rated nature
that we know Disney Plus has got to do
more fronting dignity of men
in the manatorian normalize the dong
but Samana in the mando Mandalorians is
name okay great I love it
guys I want most of all of yours to
happen I want all three of yours
solutions for how he escapes all like
that but let's just hear them back in
the form of a tweet remind us your thing
each of your theories of the order you
went and editors if we can put Eric
inside of the belly so that we remember
that element of his story all right I'll
keep mine real simple boba Java Bo
katana yada yada all right oh one more
time a little faster
boba Java Bo katana yadda yadda I mean
we all have to keep doing this right
yeah III don't know why I'm imagining
Pumbaa for some reason does thinking is
all right great what do you Bobo might
become a real Mandalore Easter eggs and
breakdowns new rock stars you know it's
always the confidence that uh people in
our profession nail and Java do rebirth
it's a bottle episode cheeks dongs
ideology Mandalorian I'm glad at some
point you mentioned what show you were
even talking actually surrounding this
uh you know what it used to be summarize
your theory but Eric Tommy it just
Twitter it's all it's all we've moved on
it it evolved in the worst way like man
uh what the exactly the outline all
right before we move on thanks so much
to expressvpn for helping us out with
making this show possible at all so a
bunch of us are stuck at home right now
are you guys roommates
yeah sure always okay so guys the whole
point of what I'm trying to say is that
you need your internet privacy
especially if you and your roommate
share a computer which it looks like you
guys do right now and using incognito
mode actually does not hide everything
because did you guys know your isp can
still see every site you visit with
whether or not you're using incognito
mode I do now oh wow thank you yeah what
can we do - you gotta use Express VPN
you use it anytime you go online Express
VPN make sure your isp cannot see where
you're going it reroutes - your internet
connection through their secure servers
and there's thousands of people on there
so because everyone's anonymous they
can't tell who's looking at what they
can tell us some people are like funky
but that's it expressvpn also encrypt
100% of your data with the best-in-class
encryption and your informations all
protected and it works on every device
that you use for internet computers
tablets smartphones you just tap a
button and you're protected it's also
the fastest and most trusted VPN on the
market and rated number one by seeing it
and wired and obviously those people are
experts on this kind of stuff so guys
protect your online activity today with
VPN that we trust for our secure privacy
visit expressvpn dot-com slash rogue
this is a PSA every week I remind people
rogue you spelled our o gue not ro ug e
that's Rouge what a beautiful color yeah
but no it's expressvpn Khan / rogue ROG
Yui and you get three months free on a
one-year package if you do that that's
expr ESS VPN comm slash rogue expressvpn
comm slash rogue to learn more guys it's
time to talk about the discord rogue
theory of the week alright so this is
where we get to dive into our fans
theories and these people are such great
like experts that sometimes their
theories are a little better than ours
so we decided to start highlighting them
based on the game that we play in
discord of rogue theory so this week we
had three selected patrons pitch the
Star Wars plot that they would like to
see taiko a TV director so this was a
topic of last week's rogue theory but
now we want to know just better ideas
than the ones we had
syndra on ironheart both really solid
solid theories but this week's winner is
son of thunder thunder guys I want to
hear your thoughts on this so this is
again Taika Waititi would be directing
this movie watching this would be an
extension of Mandalorians season two
becomes a movie where a so Gaetano is
taking baby yoda to get Jedi training
which is very similar to your theory but
I it all it takes place on Endor and the
coolest thing about this theory is that
when stormtroopers come in to attack
again the the Ewoks are so primed and
like ready now for a fight they like
destroy the stormtroopers there's a
moment in their theory where it just
cuts to he walks just eating
stormtroopers turn their guts apart what
do you guys think of ahsoka taking baby
Oda to endure and Ewoks eating
stormtroopers I think it's good he
walked Redemption right there I feel
like the Ewoks are beginning a lot more
love as of late and I think this is a
great way to showcase honestly what do
you mean as of late oh because they were
in Rises conquer I've just hear a lot of
people on the internet like a lot of
like YouTube channels we'll start
talking about you know I grew up on the
Ewoks and I think the walks are
something that people I think there was
that a walk what's that movie that came
out a few years ago is like a
straight-to-video cabbie walking I see I
see a lot of people talking about that a
lot more now cuz I think taking tyka to
do something where you kind of give a
revamp of a character or you know
characters
I think Tycho would be the best one to
do something like that and I feel like
given a great positive light - that
would be awesome
yeah couldn't you see like a
stormtrooper going like I don't know
they're kind of cute I don't want to
shoot him aren't you cute and then that
you ugh bites his fingers yeah yeah like
I I love giving more that story cuz you
know at the end of Return of the Jedi
there Drummond on this stormtrooper
helmet so like yeah they did something
we know I'm one of their head falls out
and rolls away I want to see like a Jon
Favreau chef movie but we're like with
the Ewok serving up the meat of
stormtroopers different ways
you can grill it this way I want to like
a nice ASMR e-gift video of just like
how you slice up stormtroopers rib meat
ASMR reel it on and I I mean with taiko
ITD's like what we do in the shadows
he's also like a horror comedy kind of
guy too so I think getting that in there
with you walk showing they're more
savage side that'd be pretty cool
honestly ahsoka and baby Yoda and make
it a stormtrooper
Ewok horror yeah terrifying and
delicious give it up to son of thunder
again this week discord rogue theory
clearly we got really excited about it
alright guys it's time to talk about the
little so dark Batman no Batman has ever
been so dark okay so we live in a
society how dare you so the one thing
that actually is really interesting
about this cuz we've heard that before
right we need a dark take of Batman and
we've seen dark takes but Andy Serkis
did an interview this week where you
talked about directing venom to and then
playing Alfred in the upcoming the
Batman and he said something that made
my little cow ears perk up uh that not
only that this is gonna be the darkest
Batman movie ever but that it's actually
really about the connection between
Alfred and Bruce right this is gonna be
an Alfred abreu story and it's gonna be
really dark so I want you guys to pitch
me the darkest Batman and Alfred story
you can think of all right guys get
ready because in my version Bruce
doesn't want to get there Bruce is a
sensitive child he's not having an easy
time coping with the death of his
parents or he didn't cuz we're not gonna
start their majesty Revis wants to deal
with the effects of the origin and the
effects are I mean he's left alone with
Alfred and he's got to face the world
and Alfred he's an ex-military guy he's
got the charisma he's an actor too but
he's also tough and he's also about
getting into that character so what does
he do he molds Bruce's life from the
time he's a young boy all they do is
spar read about the art of war and he
basically trains Bruce as his own
protege and I mean they're talking back
and forth
no gloves no protection I'll Fight Club
and pretty much it's gonna be a
beautiful abusive surrogate father-son
relationship where he's pushing him in
the family business
oh damn so it's kind of like Liam Neeson
in Batman Begins exactly not kind of
like Martha a mentor that abuses him
yeah Martha and Thomas they wouldn't
have wanted this yeah and Bruce dude
probably wouldn't have fallen into it
had not been for us no Rossum it's like
imagine a whiplash but with fighting
Zach LaRoche mag tempo that's awesome I
love it you already get a roadie
I say go Rocky III I can yeah creepy you
got a lot of everything and Greg only
has office supplies yeah essentials
right now speaking of Greg why don't you
go all right my version would take place
where Batman has pretty much locked away
most of his criminals a lot of them
aren't Arkham Asylum and Alfred's whole
goal this entire time has been making
sure that Bruce does not cross over to
the darkest depths of his personality
within Batman he's already at this point
where he's like he helps him out all the
time that sick-ass Batmobile that he has
in the new Batman movie Alfred helped
put that together but he's really
involved he does have a background with
Bruce where he realized like there's no
way he can change this kid from going
down a dark path so he took it upon
himself to look after him trained him
all the talks about why not to kill have
stemmed from the fact of how Alfred has
helped train his mentality in that
direction because unlike Matt Reeves
version he wants to have a little bit
more of a pathos take on Batman so
honoring that this version would go down
a wildly different path Bruce Wayne
would eventually crack and he would
start becoming a murderer as Batman and
started killing off people in his rogues
gallery he's murdering people left and
right and it's an Alfred has found a way
where he there's no way Alfred can
actually take control of this level that
Bruce
gone down so Alfred does the one thing
he thought he could never do which is
actually tell the police who Batman
really is and that it's Bruce Wayne
snitches on him Batman finds out because
he's looking outside of his home at the
Wayne Manor
drinking alcohol that's right Bruce
Wayne is an alcoholic in my version and
then he sees the cop cars coming that if
she sees a news report about how Alfred
Pennyworth ratted him out to the police
and then Bruce does the one thing he
thought he would never do he crosses to
the ultimate darkest depths becoming the
villain that he always feared he would
be by killing Alfred because Alfred
ratted him out and then now it's Batman
on the run truly rogue truly solo one
also like you know he's it's Wayne Manor
right and all the police would come in
so he also has like a little mini Waco
or something where he like has taken all
the cops yeah well Waco love it that is
hella dark ya automatically to Rogi at
all you found my cell phone thank you oh
my god I've been looking everywhere for
this thing thank you so much that's a
rose gold cellphones it's a it's
precious yeah yeah Oh Oh what do you
know Oh perfect copy only the ascendant
at Office Depot two actually so as bad
shape staples dude though very good
because also I really love the idea that
the trauma inflicted upon Batman doesn't
make him a vigilante it breaks him right
and you actually end up with Dexter yeah
where it's it's an older father figure
knows that he's got a sociopath on his
hands and it doesn't want to kill a
child
but it's like the best I can do is give
him a Creed to live by and it's you know
fine you can take people and bring
justice you just can't kill them you can
my buildings and if they happen to fall
whatever boy and then he crosses over
and then having to take each other out
great job very exciting I want it to be
bad so far yeah but Eric top it show
them how it's done you're their mental
Lord boss by the way he started by like
senpai notice me and now he's like bring
it I'm the Batman in my story so I'm
going dark
I think the movies gonna open with
Alfred Pennyworth murder
I think he's mean damn in the opening
minutes of the movie so what happened
what happened so we've seen some like
set photos that have come out right some
of them are legit we don't really know
but we know there is some murder victim
whose face has been wrapped up in
cellophane with words no more lies
written on it we also know that a Batman
figure we don't know if it's like the
real Batman or stunt guy or whatever is
visiting a cemetery in in the Edinburgh
area and I think he's visiting our first
grave so the murder of Alfred is is set
Bruce Wayne into a tailspin because it's
reach triggered all the emotional trauma
of his own parents murder but now he's
like reliving that with this other
pseudo father figure to him he realized
that Alfred was more of a father to him
than his parents were throughout his
life so he's lost another dad so he with
this death though is this mystery who
murdered him and why was it this like
symbolic murder what does a message no
more lies mean well Bruce begins to dig
into Alfred's paperwork and he finds out
that Alfred knew dark political secret
about the coming of Gotham mayoral
election and that a mayoral candidate
may be Peter SARS guards character has
an illegitimate son who has gone dark
and is now like a serial murderer
throughout the city of Gotham who is
killing all these people he believes
that one of these people was Alfred and
Alfred knew that secret and he used the
Sun as like a hit man to go against
Alfred so Batman is investigating this
crime and then other people will begin
to die the wealthy elite of Gotham begin
to die Oswald Cobblepot dies it's it's
crazy there's blood all over this and
while investigating
is further he realized by the end of it
it's not exactly the conspiracy theory
that we thought the murderer is the son
of Alfred who as a child killed someone
got sent to juvie
Alfred disowned him and he had to sit he
had to detach himself from his son and
then reapply all of his paternal
affection on to Bruce Wayne and raise
him as a son that he could no longer
have eventually that son came back to
suffocate him and murder him because we
realized that the person he killed was
Alfred's ex-wife who he put a bag over
her head wrapped it around her she
killed her and now it's come back around
to kill Alfred but that kid had a little
brother named Jason Jason Todd
pennyworth yeah Alfred hood alright
alright Eric I love it I just want you
to just tag one more thing and just
point out for everyone something that
you were too subtle about who would this
kid have more hatred toward in the world
then Bruce Wayne
so that becomes a battle at the end of
it he killed Alfred in order to get to
Bruce Wayne's heart and realize killing
him wouldn't make him feel anything but
killing his father figure would break
his heart and make him live with that
the way that this murder had to live
without having a father yeah it's us
they're our surrogate brothers in a way
having to battle it out oh great job
that's three rogue E's for mr. Eric
Klaus whoa three and they can't be
Sparkle bucks Oh too late they already
are because now I got a space Sparkle
buck and a reality Sparkle bug and a
souls from the bug Melanie two more
what's gonna happen if we get to all six
I don't know half the views are great
all right guys let's hear these dark
tweets let's try to summarize our
theories in these tweets dark tweets
bring them back abusive father Batman
great hashtag Mandalore
yes
what's your tweet Bruce Wayne now as an
alcoholic crosses over into the
territory that he never thought he would
be the villain hashtag circus yeah why's
a hashtag trendy its trendy its trendy
now now that I said it yeah okay my
tweet is just a very confusing tweet for
Matt Reeves that says Alf dead and then
Alf starts trending because everyone so
wide would be like oh no we're good and
then denzel's gift starts trending of
like oh god I thought Alfred I think I
think I'm finally getting this tweet
game now you guys made more sense than
Eric's every week now is starting with
sends our really confusing tweet
misinterpreted and then yeah we have to
explain it in a tweet down all right
guys it's time for Road questions I know
some of these scores are tied so this
could be the tiebreaker you ready yes
yeah
number one Michael Douglas said on
instagram this week that news about
ant-man 3 might be coming soon before
joking that Marvel henchmen were about
to dart him he's so funny
besides giving away a spoiler what would
make Marvel henchman Dart you stealing
Kevin Feige x' hat cuz he's just got
like a exposed brain under that I think
Disney would dart me for becoming that
guy who just started agents of shield
season 3 and is about to tell you how
great it isn't how much it should have
played into the movies dammit uh yeah
for reacting to a new rock stars video
and debunking all their theories and
then being a little too close to home
for Marvel you think Marvel's really on
our startles definitely on your side
they're not paying you guys I thought
they're paying you guys that's why we
agree to be here today
yeah I thought we were nobody in the
house no mouth anything yeah if people
were paying us you think we'd be Hawking
hand sanitizer which by the way a bitly
his /nr chill you can buy some hand
sanitizer we're to the New Mutants is
supposedly still getting the Thea
release sure yeah nobody knows when
pitch me on the updated title that this
movie has to be given cuz they're not
new anymore New Mutants mutant harder
the new New Mutants
seriously though my title is like five
years from now when everyone is homeless
and living on the street and the title
is just trying to be relevant to that
and it's called too few tents too few
tents too few tents
number three General Mills is releasing
the Mandalorians cereal with baby Yoda
shaped marshmallows what would go to
sound like eating baby Yoda cereal tasty
we are so much refined sugar you've
eaten blah blah kill me you must uh uh
Eric gets a rocky for that one because I
like the image just puppet baby it with
practical effects now we have to know
what happens irresponsible to award him
anymore roadies actually let's find out
if it is what are all our point to
littles I've got four I think I think
Aris got five I've got I've got five
Rogi Oh Eric won yeah that makes clothes
gosh he goes and new rock stars man I
was ready to give it up Eric could sign
the contract he's like whoever dethrones
me today that's right I gets the job
yeah yeah alright guys so that means
Eric's our winner Eric oh what's your
wish
[ __ ] forgot about the wisps part okay so
what are we talking I will give John my
job okay so um so we all have to say
what we think Boba Fett's final line
should have been in Return of the Jedi
other than just a scream as he tumbled
into the pit
oh they're called eye drops doctor touch
yeah that sounds about right give
yourself a Wragge yeah yeah alright guys
that's it for this episode of road
theory thank you so much to our guest
guys plug yourselves how can I find you
on the real rejects a YouTube channel
and on patreon a patreon real rejects
the greg alba on instagram and twitter
dad John Humphrey on Instagram and
Twitter check them out these guys are
great if you like our content you'll
like their content cuz they're huge
ripoffs of us yeah exactly
no I'm just kidding no we don't do
anything like what you guys do and you
guys are great fans and I'm so glad you
guys came on we'd love to have you this
is seriously an honor thank you Eric
anything you want to plug watch a new
rock stars video and hey there's there
are some other people who are afraid to
put themselves on camera who do this
kind of work that for whatever reason
during this quarantine you all are
flocking to why not give some love to
the brave nerds who put themselves on
camera try to make jokes and put
themselves out there very vulnerable
difficult we so congratulate our mental
health is delicate alright guys that's
it for this episode thanks so much
everybody thank you not forget to
subscribe to rogue theory podcast feed
stay tuned to our YouTube channel for
everything that we're somehow still
pumping out Eric's a big part of that
but thanks to all our supporters on
patreon - for making this happen and of
course expressvpn sign up for that thing
cuz it really does help us follow
Twitter at new rock stars follow me uh
it says here follow me at EA boss yeah
that's what they do that's all they do
alright that's it have a good one guys
bye
[Music]